By now, we have introduced
all sorts of PMFs for
the discrete case.
The joint PMF, the
conditional PMF--
given an event--
and the conditional PMF of one
random variable given another.
And we're moving along with
the program of defining
analogous concepts for
the continuous case.
We have already discussed the
joint PDF and the conditional
PDF, given an event.
The next item in our menu is to
define a conditional PDF of
one random variable, given
another random variable.
We proceed by first looking
at the definition for the
discrete case.
A typical entry of the
conditional PMF is just a
conditional probability, but
in different notation.
And using the definition of
conditional probabilities,
this is equal to the ratio of
the joint divided by the
probability of the conditioning
event.
Unfortunately, in the continuous
case, a definition
of this form would be
problematic, because the event
that Y takes on a specific value
is an event that has 0
probability.
And we know that we cannot
condition on a
0 probability event.
However, we can take this
expression as a guide on how
to define a conditional PDF
in the continuous case.
And this is the definition,
which just mimics the formula
that we have up here.
Notice that this conditional
PDF-- defined this way-- is
well defined, as long
as the denominator
is a positive quantity.
Let us now try to make sense
of this definition.
Let us first recall the
interpretation of the
conditional PDF, given an event,
A, that has positive
probability.
We know that the PDF is used to
determine the probability
of a small interval.
And similarly, the conditional
PDF is used to calculate the
conditional probability of a
small interval given the
conditioning event.
We would like to do something
similar for the conditional
PDF, where we would like to
take the event A to be
something like the event that Y
is equal to some particular
value-- little y.
But as we said, this is
problematic, because this
event does not have positive
probability.
So instead, we can take A to
be the event that Y is
approximately equal to
a certain value.
So we're dealing with a little
interval around this value,
little y, which in general would
be an event of positive
probability.
And we can try to have a
similar interpretation.
Let us see how this works out.
So what does it mean that Y is
approximately equal to some
particular value, little y?
We interpret that as follows.
We're told that the random
variable, Y, takes a value
that is within epsilon--
where epsilon is a
small number--
of a given value, little y.
And given this conditioning
information, we want to
calculate the probability
of a small interval.
How do we do that?
Well, here--
because this, in general,
will be a
positive probability event--
we can use the definition of
conditional probabilities.
And it would be equal to the
probability of both events
happening, divided by the
probability of the
conditioning event.
What is the probability of
both events happening?
This is a probability of a small
rectangle in xy space.
At that rectangle, the joint
PDF, has a certain value.
And because we're integrating
over that rectangle--
and that rectangle has
dimensions delta and epsilon--
of that probability, that
small rectangle, is
approximately equal to this.
Then we need the denominator,
which is the probability of
the conditioning event.
And this is approximately equal
to the density of Y
evaluated at that point,
times the length
of the small interval.
We cancel the epsilons.
And then we notice that the
ratio we have here is what we
defined as the conditional
PDF.
So we get this relation
times delta.
So what do we see?
We see that the probability of a
small interval is equal to a
PDF times the length of
the small interval.
However, because we are
conditioning on Y being
approximately equal to a certain
value, we end up using
a corresponding conditional PDF,
where the conditional PDF
is defined this way.
So we now have an interpretation
of the
conditional PDF in terms of
probabilities of small intervals.
Now that we have an intuitive
interpretation of the
conditional PDF, we can also
use it to calculate
conditional probabilities
of more general
events, not just intervals.
And we do this as follows.
In general, for continuous
random variables, we can find
the probability that X belongs
to a certain set by
integrating a PDF
over that set.
Because here we're dealing with
a conditional situation
where we're given the value of
Y, we use the conditional PDF
instead of the true PDF.
And this way, we calculate the
conditional probability.
Now, the difficulty is that this
conditional probability
is not a well-defined quantity
according to what we did early
on in this class.
We cannot condition on zero
probability events.
But we can get the around this
difficulty as follows.
This quantity is well-defined.
And we can use this quantity
as the definition of this
conditional probability.
And so we have managed to
provide definition of
conditional probabilities, given
a 0 probability event of
a certain type.
It turns out that this
definition is sound and
consistent with everything
else that we are doing.
But when we're dealing with
particular problems and
applications, we can generally
forget about all of these
subtleties that we have
been discussing here.
The bottom line is
that we will be
treating conditional PDFs--
given the value of a random
variable, Y--
just as ordinary PDFs, but given
the information that
this random variable took
on a specific value.
And in that conditional
universe, we will calculate
probabilities the usual way,
by using conditional PDFs
instead of ordinary PDFs.